Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhet.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are talking about 10
people that we are jealous of,
each.
Oh.
So potentially 20,
unless there's crossover.
There might be crossover. I don't know.
We don't reveal these lists to each other.
I don't know your list,
but I feel like we're going to be jealous
of the same people.
There might be 100% crossover.
What if that happened?
People would be so jealous of us.
Well, the reason I don't
think that's gonna happen
is because this wasn't as easy...
Or even though coming up
with your favorite artists
or your favorite albums
or whatever is not easy;
but there's a narrow field,
it's like I'm choosing from albums.
When you're choosing from anyone
that you can be jealous of,
it's like, well, there's people...
You can be jealous of people
for all kinds of different reasons,
as I think I tried to capture in the list.
Yeah.
When we did the top 10
inspirations, it kind of...
As I started to think about it,
momentum started to build
and a loose ranking started to take form.
With this, it's more of like,
"Well, I don't know if this
is good for my mental health,"
but I think it is, just
to put it out there,
just to put out the jealousy
and just kind of put it in its place.
But then I started having trouble
coming up with specific
people and I'm like,
"Wow, maybe I'm not that jealous,"
but then I'm like,
"You know what?
I'm just not thinking of everybody.
I bet Rhett's gonna jog my memory
and I'ma be like,
'Man, I'm a jealous person.'"
Well, I don't see...
I guess I didn't take this as
the negative side of jealousy,
which obviously jealousy
is not good in general,
but people who have something,
there's some aspect of their lives
that I would like to have in my life.
Yeah.
That's how I went about this.
I think it really hits home.
There's a couple on my list
that like the sweet spot for me
is I could see that it could be me
or I want it to be me,
and so there's like
actual jealousy of like,
"Man, I'm..."
Almost, "I'm envious of
what this person is doing
or is able to do
because I feel like I should
be in that person's position."
Ooh.
There's a few of those.
Well,
I don't think there's anybody on my list
that I actually feel
like I could aspire to.
All right.
Well-
And one qualifier,
that we did discuss ahead of time,
we didn't put each other
on each other's list.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because we could do a whole episode
about things that we're
jealous of each other about.
I'm not saying we're going to,
it might be a good episode idea.
I think it is like an episode idea
in the long list of episode ideas.
Speaking of episode ideas, last week, boy,
I had a fun time listening
to those voicemails.
♪ 1-888- EARPOD1 ♪
Listen up,
when you are listening to us right now
and you have some sort of reaction,
I want you to call that number
and leave a verbal reaction.
I would love to be able to
put reactions to the episode
at the end of episodes, if
we get enough good ones,
just like as kind of a
closing credits thing.
Reaction to the previous episode.
To the previous...
Yeah, to like-
'Cause then
that would be impossible.
Yeah, the previous episode.
I used to listen to a podcast
called "Sound Opinions" a lot.
I've fallen out of it.
Sometimes I go back to it,
depending on what albums
they're reviewing.
But they do that at the
end of their podcast,
and I always like it.
Oh, I love the voicemails.
Yeah.
And even the reactions
to the previous episode montage at the end
is specifically what I'm talking about.
Yeah, yeah. I like that too.
♪ 1-888-EARPOD1 ♪
Now, in that episode,
we pushed something we
were gonna talk about
at the beginning
that I think you've
totally forgotten about,
but I remember,
and I think we can make
it into a whole episode
as early as next week.
You remember?
I do.
But then I thought we-
We talked about the fight that we had
instead of talking about
the thing that you had
on your laptop,
which I don't wanna reveal.
But you think-
Involving lyrics.
Oh, you think we can make a
whole episode out of lyrics?
No, we didn't tell people what it was,
so I don't want to give it away, but like-
Okay.
'Cause I thought we...
There was two episode ideas in that.
Oh.
One was talking about...
Which I'll just go ahead and say this one
'cause we're not gonna do it now.
'Cause the story started with me,
the fact that Shepherd
is going to like a middle school dance
and Locke is going to prom.
Oh not that 'cause that's old news.
And I was like,
"Well, we can't do that now
because everybody will
have gone to their dances
and their proms," but-
Until...
So next year-
We need to remember that.
When we're gearing up
for dance season.
'Cause I got lots of great dad advice
about both of these events.
We'll have to hit that
in the next dance season.
Because Shepherd started
asking me, he was like,
"What was your middle school dance like?"
and I said, "Oh, you've asked
your dad a great question,"
so-
Which Led to you wanting
to talk about the lyrics
to a specific song that
we were into at that age,
that now-
Which I played for him
on the way into school.
Now reading it back, it's like...
So I think that analysis of the lyrics
that went over our heads
as middle schoolers-
Is a good idea for a whole episode.
Is a fun episode.
I agreed with that.
Maybe as early as next week.
Let us know.
#EARBISCUITS.
Let us know what lyrics from songs
went over your head as a kid.
I'm making this a prompt.
Do it now.
Oh gosh.
And then maybe in the next episode-
But probably not in the next episode.
I don't know how the
timing works for recording.
Probably not in the next episode.
It's true.
But
probably two episodes from now.
Let's get on our list,
do you want to go first,
of who you're jealous of
or you want me to go first?
You go first.
You wanna Rock Paper Scissors?
I can hit you with a banger
using the parlance of this person-
And if somebody-
As my first one.
If somebody on your list is better than...
I'm more jealous of somebody on your list,
I have to choose somebody
on my list to knock off,
vice versa.
Oh really?
That would be fun, yeah.
So the episode withers away.
The ending of the episode dissolves
because of the middle.
No,
we'll still talk about all of them,
but you know.
Oh, but they'll go off of the list.
I wasn't really precious about the order.
And matter of fact,
this is my number nine
that I'm now making my number 10,
'cause I wanna hit you with this.
Okay.
This one's real.
This is one of those ones
that I feel a little
uncomfortable putting out there.
Oh.
And I'm just gonna do it.
I am freaking jealous of MrBeast.
Oh, okay. See?
Yeah, I didn't think about this.
You know, freaking MrBeast, man.
Now, I've had a one-on-one...
I've had a personal phone
conversation with Jimmy, you know?
Did you tell him you were jealous of him?
The person behind MrBeast.
It's been...
I might have been a year ago.
Well, yeah, it was
definitely in pandemic times.
And okay, you may be saying,
"Well, why are you jealous of MrBeast?"
Of course 'cause he's like so...
He's popping.
Because he's on the cover
of a "Rolling Stone."
That's why.
Dude got on the cover of a magazine
that gets delivered to my house.
I don't want...
You know...
I like getting the
"Rolling Stone" magazine.
I mean, I've had this secret dream.
What if...
You know, it's one of those iconic things
to be on the cover of the "Rolling Stone,"
there's even a song about it,
being on the cover of the "Rolling Stone."
And I don't want another creator
coming on a magazine in my home.
That didn't sound right.
Yeah, I definitely don't want that.
I don't want another creator showing up-
Depending on the type of magazine, though-
At my doorstep-
That can happen.
On a freaking magazine cover that I enjoy.
Man, it just, it really brought
something up inside of me;
jealousy, like, "I
wanna be on that cover."
You know what?
You could be there too.
But really, do you...
But...
I don't think I have any
business being there.
Right. We don't deserve
to be on the cover.
Yeah, but I never thought he did either.
But he does.
But then its, oh,
it's the creator issue.
We're not even in the conversation.
And so here's-
So it's like, yeah, I'm jealous.
I agree that we-
And does MrBeast
deserve to be on the cover?
This is not about
MrBeast, this is about me.
Well, okay.
And Jimmy, if you think
it's about you, call me,
you still have my number.
And if I keep this up,
I'm gonna have to call
you and pre-apologize.
Yeah, I'm trying to cut you off
so you can quit digging your own hole.
I thought about calling him and saying,
"You know what?
Congratulations,"
or at least texting-
It's not working.
"Congratulations on being on
the cover of "Rolling Stone,"
but I was too jealous to do it.
So he definitely deserves
to be on the cover of
"Rolling Stone," we do not.
I can unequivocally say that.
He might deserve to be
on the cover "WIRED,"
or something where they...
Like, for "Rolling Stone"
to all of a sudden have a
creator issue is reaching anyway.
If they're doing a creator issue,
then he deserves to be on the cover of it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Swimming in money.
So that's what I'm saying.
But we deserved to be
in the creator issue,
I think that.
We're just...
We're boring.
We're boring to people
like "Rolling Stone."
We're not...
I mean-
We gotta do something about
this headphone placement.
We've got
that boring success, you know?
We don't have that flashy,
swimming in money success.
It's like, I mean, we
did something wrong, man.
We should have been giving
away money for years
and making a big viral woo hoo about it.
Do you want my honest opinion on this
or do you want me to go along with the bit
that you're doing?
My...
I'm...
You think this is a bit?
I know you don't actually feel
as strongly as you're acting right now.
Okay.
I mean, I don't know, man.
Because you and I both know that, yes...
I mean, first of all,
no one is getting excited about...
I mean I'm not saying that
we're the victims of ageism,
but no one's getting it excited
about a 44-year-old and 44...
Well, soon to be 45 and 44-year-old dudes
who make YouTube videos
and been doing it for as long as we have.
He is much flashier and more exciting,
and he's...
I mean, just look at the
traction that he gets
on an individual video.
It's mind blowing.
And yeah, it's like I wish
we could come up with an idea
that would do that at
this point in our career,
but I wouldn't trade our career to do it.
I'm very proud of what we've accomplished
in terms of the longevity of our career
and the trajectory of our career,
but I acknowledge that
it's not the kind of thing
that should get you on the
cover of "Rolling Stone"
because it's kind of a boring story.
It would be like,
"These guys on the
cover of 'Rolling Stone'
have a very successful
digital media company
that has been steadily
growing for a decade."
Who cares?
In terms of-
Hold on.
Let's say at least 15 years.
But I'm saying in terms of
from the "Rolling Stone" level,
person on the cover of "Rolling Stone,"
you gotta be somebody that's like,
"This is sensational."
He, by definition, is a sensational...
Everything that he does is sensational.
And so name the person
that's been on the
cover of "Rolling Stone"
who wasn't doing sensational things.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So my question is:
Do you really want to be on
the cover of "Rolling Stone"?
We are not a sensation, period.
And you know what?
That's been a key to our success.
Unsensational.
But honestly,
the moment the article was
sent to me and it was like,
"Hate to break it to you,
but MrBeast is on the cover,"
I read that thing.
And the reason why I read it
was to make myself feel
better about it not being us.
It's like,
"What about this piece on
MrBeast can make me feel better
about not being as sensational as him?"
And I'm not gonna say how I
reacted to certain parts of it.
But yeah,
it's kind of like when I
listen to John Mayer sing
and he's talking about how all just...
he wishes he had a wife and kids.
And I'm like, "Okay yeah,
that's good for me to
hear 'cause I got that.
I got something at your
age that you don't have."
Right.
And he doesn't have anything that we want.
He has a full sleeve,
and it's like,
I would like to have a full sleeve
tattoo.
He's on my list list.
Oh, oh, okay.
He's actually-
We'll get to that.
He's actually not on my list list.
But I'm not done talking about MrBeast.
I got another 10 minutes of jealousy
that I just need to work out.
Well, you should do that
on like your side project.
My side piece?
Yeah.
Yeah, I can move on.
So you know what?
I'm adding MrBeast to my list
because I wasn't thinking
about any digital creators.
It's like I was sort of
thinking about categories,
and I didn't think about that.
But yeah, I am also jealous of him.
You didn't think about digital creators?
Interesting.
No.
Okay.
Interesting.
I think actually this...
The fact that I didn't
think about digital creators
is an indication of the way
that I think about jealousy
and the way I think about...
The of the people on my
list that I aspire to,
it's things that I want.
And I'm like, "I've got the
digital creator thing going."
Yeah, I'm not on the
cover of "Rolling Stone,"
but I wasn't thinking
in that category at all.
You know what we should do, though?
Move on?
I was telling Christy this.
I think you're gonna be into this.
I just want to go ahead
and put it out there.
I'm gonna pitch this to you.
Okay.
I've kind of soft pitched this,
but I don't think you
understood that I meant it.
We could be sensational,
and I have the way to do it.
Oh no, no, no.
I don't wanna...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
And this is a horrible idea.
About getting naked?
I want us to pose nude
in a magazine.
Yeah, you can do that.
Okay. Fine.
It feels desperate.
It depends on how it looks.
I mean, Flula was on
the cover of "Hustler."
Flula was on the cover of "Hustler,"
and he looked great.
And he didn't look desperate, trust me.
I would box you
before I get naked.
Nothing about that heinie
looked desperate to me.
Tell us more.
I would box you before I would get naked.
I didn't get to see the
inside of the magazine
'cause I didn't purchase it.
He didn't show his, if
that's what you're asking.
Yeah, great.
I don't wanna show my wang either.
Perfect.
Okay, well, I'm not prepared to do that.
Oh no, we'll have to train for it.
I think it'll be a great
way for us, personally,
to really turn a corner.
I'll get naked with you in a magazine
because I'll have to train
in order to be ready;
but if I'm gonna train,
I'm also going to fight
you in a boxing ring.
No, I'm not gonna.
No, I wanna look pretty.
I wanna look...
We'll take the photos
before I beat the hell outta you.
No.
It's all on the same day.
The morning is the photo shoot
and the night is the boxing match.
Dude, I don't even know.
What is this freaking...
Like Matt Watson got the
crap beat out of him by...
What's his name?
Nathan Barnatt.
Nathan freaking Barnatt
just went after the guy.
They call him Dad now.
We just know Nathan because we used to...
We made videos back in the day with him.
I mean, it was brutal.
And first of all-
I don't know anything about the event.
No one invited us.
Oh, well, but now that
we're talking about it,
they will.
'Cause we're not sensational
enough.
Yeah. Yeah.
But here's the thing-
Maybe they think we're above it.
We're not above anything.
I'm taking it all back, I'm...
For me, this is all a bit.
I'm not going to box you.
I'm not going to get naked
because I just think it...
I think it's a sign of desperation.
I'm not saying I won't
get there at some point,
but I'm not ready to get there.
I just think it will be fun.
Like, Christy didn't love the idea,
but I'm gonna wear her down.
Lando, he hated the idea.
So I think it's really like...
I think Lando might need to be...
He might need to graduate from high school
before this happens.
The last kid needs to be out of the house.
Well, you're just making
it tougher and tougher
on yourself.
Right.
Which makes it more sensational.
Yeah.
Okay, well we can consider it.
When Lando graduates from high school,
we'll talk about it again.
What's your number 10?
Ja Morant.
Don't know the guy/girl.
I don't know what...
What? John Morant?
Ja
Ja?
Morant.
What is that?
Well, what is that?
Who is that, is a better question.
He's a NBA basketball player
for the Memphis Grizzlies.
And he is like-
What?
So I picked an athlete,
and this is my number 10,
because whenever I watch
professional sports,
I am jealous of the way that these guys
can move their bodies
and accomplish things physically
that I would...
my body would break in
the process of doing it.
And so just like...
I mean, if you know, you know.
You know what I'm saying?
So now I'm not talking to Link,
I'm talking to you.
To watch this guy play
basketball and to see-
Can I take a bathroom break now?
And to see him...
I was like,
"I'm gonna pick somebody from the NBA,
who is it gonna be?"
And then the most exciting,
physically impressive,
in terms of what he can...
Like, he's like 6'3"
but just flies over people
and does all this stuff.
And he's young,
he's only been in the
league like two years.
So it's like, "Oh, I'm gonna pick LeBron."
But no, LeBron's old now.
So it's more of the athleticism
than being a basketball player.
You're not jealous of being an NBA player,
you're jealous of his capabilities.
I'll take being an NBA player as well.
It's not necessarily a
lifestyle that I aspire to.
The specific thing that I am jealous of
is just his ability
to basically make it look
like he's doing magic.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay.
So you got somebody like Steph Curry-
But the way that this hits home,
I think the way that it
really is true jealousy
is like you're feeling the
limitations of your own body.
And I love to compete and I love sports,
and I loved playing sports.
But-
This is real.
I can't play pickup basketball
anymore because it's like,
"Ah, I might hurt my back," or,
"My shoulder a little bit messed up."
You know what I'm saying?
So-
Oh, there's real pain here.
I'm sorry.
And so instead of picking
somebody like Steph Curry,
who's obviously super exciting to watch,
but like Steph just
goes up and lays it in.
Like, Ja Morant is doing
Steph Curry type things
but then he just keeps going to the basket
and then jumps over somebody and dunks it.
And I would just love to
see what that feels like.
You don't think there's
any amount of training
that you could do
with the hope that physical
therapy has given you
with your shoulder
that you could be able to
play pickup basketball again?
Not like Ja Morant.
I know, but to-
I could be like the-
Isn't there a way
that you could at least
play pickup basketball?
I mean-
Yeah,
but it wouldn't be fun.
My papa's brother-
'Cause I would be like
bracing the whole time-
Played in a senior
citizen basketball league
back in North Carolina,
they were state champions.
He was a senior citizen state
champion basketball player.
He traveled the state playing basketball.
I'm not interested in that.
Okay. All right.
Fine.
If I'm gonna compete,
I wanna compete at the highest level,
not at the Y.
Okay.
No,
I would be in to pickup basketball
and I would be maybe doing it
if I wouldn't have to be like.
When you have to play
in a compromised state
and you're basically like,
"You know, I would be good.
You guys don't know how good I would be.
I would actually be contributing,
but now I'm just kinda stand
in there with my stomach
flexed to protect my back."
Just say you're posting up.
Yeah. Right.
See if you know, you know.
I know.
And now I know who that guy is.
Check out Sporked,
they have rankings that
tell you what to get
at the grocery store.
Do you go to the grocery store?
Do you wanna know what...
I mean,
do you need something
to make going shopping
at the grocery store more exciting?
Well, go to Sporked-
Or just more accurate.
They can give you some
things to get excited about
that you can try because
they've tried it all.
And they're adding stuff
constantly to the site.
I don't know how many items
get added in a week or a day,
but literally they're
constantly tasting stuff.
Whenever I see one of the
Sporked people in the office,
I'm like, "What you
been tasting that day?"
And they'll be like,
"Well, I just tried 25 mayonnaises, and-"
It's a beautiful thing.
"I'm moving on to graham crackers."
You know, it's like-
It blows my mind that people
can be critical of Sporked
because it is a freaking service.
I mean, it's a freaking service.
And there's fun personalities
that are contributing to it.
You know, you're gonna be critical of it?
Well, we touched a nerve.
Who you talking about?
I mean, I don't get it.
Who's critical of it?
I don't get it.
Some fans are like...
You feel like everything you put out,
you need to be critical of it.
It's a tool that tells you,
based on a group of people that we trust,
including us, that say,
"This is what you should
buy at the grocery store."
And you find a way to complain about it?
It's like having somebody
out in front of the
grocery store who's like,
"Hey, here's a list of the best
stuff in the grocery store,"
and you're like, "Well,
I don't like your list."
Sporked.com.
"I don't like your font."
All right.
Here is my number nine.
I'm jealous of Lil Yachty.
Oh yes.
Lil Yachty, hip hop artist extraordinaire.
I met the guy.
Lincoln and I met him
at the video game awards thing.
You were there.
You were not there.
I met him.
You were there.
Yeah, you met him too.
Yeah. Yeah.
I didn't understand-
I didn't know who he was at that time.
I wish I understood more about like-
I just knew he was a rapper.
What an entertaining person he is,
just even apart from his music career.
He's adventurous.
Lil Yachty is adventurous.
He signs up for cool stuff.
And all of that is inspiring,
the things on the internet
that he shows up on..
Lil Yachty, come on
"Good Mythical Morning."
Let's do this.
All that's inspiring, but
that doesn't make me jealous.
The thing that makes me jealous
is that he's onto Reese's Puffs cereal.
It's a freaking Lil Yachty
collab with Reese's Puffs cereal.
He's on the front of it?
It's a special box.
Have you got it?
Lincoln has it?
Yeah.
Cut it out, hang it up.
I'm freaking jealous of it.
You gotta hold onto that kind of thing.
Like I wanna...
He has it displayed in his room.
Oh, good, good.
Unopened.
I go in there sometimes
at like 2:00 in the morning thinking,
"If we're outta cereal,
I'ma eat that Reese Puffs cereal
that he has on his shelf."
As long as you open the box
carefully.
And I go in there and
Lincoln's still awake.
It's like I keep staying
up later and later
hoping that he'll go to sleep
so that I can eat that
Reese's Puff cereal.
And no matter how late I stay up,
he's always up later
because he knows that
I'm after that cereal.
I just feel like...
I feel like we should be on a cereal box.
We should be on a cereal, man.
It's like-
Yeah, I agree with this.
Lil Yachty deserves it, but don't...
I mean, we have a morning show,
people eat cereal and watch our show.
I think it's tougher to
get two people on a box.
Well-
One of us has gotta take the front,
one of us gotta the back.
His face is not it at all.
It's just a collab that-
It's just his chest?
It's not...
It says Lil Yachty on it
but it doesn't show his face on the front.
What?
I'm picturing him
with a spoon.
It's not like Wheaties.
That would be awesome.
Yeah, I don't know why
they didn't do that.
But even that...
So it's at a level that
I feel like we could do.
Are we gonna have to make our own cereal
in order to get on the box?
Yeah, I'm sure that can be arranged.
Yeah.
Like back in 2008,
we made our own freaking shoe
just so we could collab on a shoe.
Shout out to Tweak.
Okay.
What's your number nine?
See, I'm just tapping into the anger.
Like yes, I'm playing it up-
I find it interesting.
I find your angle interesting.
But no,
it's actually jealousy.
I wasn't expecting anger.
Well,
I'm just wondering if you're going
in more of an inspirational direction,
like if you're not really tapping
into the hurt of jealousy.
Well, take this.
Number nine, Jason Momoa.
Okay?
Okay. Yeah.
There you go.
I mean, I should have
put him higher, maybe.
Yeah. Why is he number nine?
Well, just because there's a lot of people
that I'm jealous of,
and because the thing that I
am jealous of Jason Momoa about
is very superficial.
It's the way he looks, period.
Now, first of all,
he's lived an exciting life.
He gets to do...
He's got a cool job, being an actor.
He's always doing stuff
that seems like he's living
an adventurous and fun
life, he's into cool stuff,
so I guess I'm jealous of that.
But the thing that I think
about when I think about him
is the fact that even when I roast myself,
like in our TikTok
where we went into the boardroom
and found the other Rhett and
Link who work here with us
and I called myself a
bargain bin Jason Momoa.
And then even when I started
growing out my hair...
And Jessie obviously had
a crush on Jason Momoa,
and she's been vocal about that,
and that's fine.
I mean, that's...
Of course, right?
I'm not surprised.
But then when you start
making a decision...
My decision to grow out my hair
wasn't to look more like Jason Momoa,
it was for all the reasons
that I've explained.
But then once you realize
that that's what's happening in effect,
then you start realizing
how there's just things about Jason Momoa
that you will never
actually achieve physically.
I mean, obviously he
has a jaw, a lower jaw,
which is helpful;
I don't have one of those, necessarily.
I mean, I could probably stick
my head into a smaller hole
to get something out than he can,
if it comes to that.
The old head through the whole retrieval
advantage.
If somebody's gotta force
their head into a small culvert
to extract a baby with their
mouth or something like that,
then you're probably gonna
call on me instead of Momoa.
No, I think they would
just use their hand.
And everybody's hands are not functioning
in this particular universe.
But then when we were talking to Kimmy,
who styles us for our public appearances
on like "Fallon" and such,
and then I find myself...
You know, I guess I'm sort of,
kind of doing like more of a Momoa thing,
and then she brings back-
Yeah, you have to say that out lout.
And then she brings back
her interpretation of,
"Well, this is kind of.."
So what I wore on "Fallon"
is the most Momoa that I
have been in public, right?
And you just start realizing
that you're on this...
Just like Mr. Bryant used to say,
"I've never seen an
asymptote touch its..."
"I've never seen a function
touch its asymptote."
That's our physics teacher in-
And math teacher.
High school.
And so I feel like I am
on a asymptotic function,
trying to achieve Jason Momoa-ishness
but never being capable of it.
So it's a little bit of a-
Well, you imply that you
get really close, though.
Yeah. I mean-
But it might be when you're both 80.
That's true. Yeah.
And you know...
Okay, so now I've now I've
heard from a second person,
right?
A second person?
So some of our close friends,
their daughter is an actor
who was in a movie with him
that I don't know when it's coming out,
but they got to know
him fairly well, right?
Yeah.
And so he has been shown my photo shoot
that you did for me of
me dressed up like him,
and then also my Halloween costume
of me dressed up like him,
and so to the point now...
And I've never met Jason.
We were gonna be on
"Fallon" at the same time,
but it didn't end up working out.
But I've been told that the last time
that our friend was with him on set,
and he was talking to somebody else,
he turned to her and said,
"Hey, show him your friend
that dresses up like me."
Oh yes.
And so-
Oh.
And then I was at a party the other night-
"That dresses up like me."
Yeah, that's who I am to him.
Your friend who dresses up like me.
You're becoming that to me too.
Yeah. Yeah.
And so-
Our friend who up like Jason Momoa.
I was at birthday party the other night
that you were also invited to
but you couldn't go cause
you were outta town.
And I was talking to my
friend at this party,
and he has another connection to Momoa.
He's good friends with a guy
that was directing or working with Jason.
And so he saw what I had done on Instagram
and he sends it to his
friend and he is like,
"Hey, send this to Jason.
This is my friend."
And then the guy was like,
"He's already seen it."
He's already seen it?
Basically-
Because he had told the director,
"Look at this guy who dresses up like me"?
He's going around telling people-
My impression is that he's going around
telling people that there's a guy
that dresses up like him,
and I'm that guy.
So he should be jealous of me.
That's like Jim Morrison in hiding saying,
"Look at this band that
covers all of our songs."
You know, it's like...
It's just a weird thing.
Shall we move on?
Yeah, sure.
I don't need to rub your nose in it,
you're already-
I've done that.
You've already done that.
My number eight is...
It's kind of a toss up.
I'ma put these two together, okay?
Because I was gonna put a street sweeper,
and I'm talking about the occupation.
Okay.
It's like, you see these Zamboni machines
that go down residential streets
and city streets?
Yeah.
It's called street sweepers.
I'm familiar with the street sweeper.
It's like a awesome machine-
Now, growing up, we
didn't know about this.
We didn't know about it.
So maybe if you live out in a country,
you don't know about it.
I was walking Jasper this morning
and we had an encounter with
one of 'em, and I was like,
"This is going on my list.
I'm jealous of that pilot of that thing.
I wish I was piloting a
street Zamboni right now."
What was the look on his face?
I didn't see his or her face at all
'cause the street sweeper was
going the other direction.
But there's so much power under...
You're sitting on so much power
and you're cleaning things,
and there's a route, and you're alone,
you can listen to whatever you want.
And then I realized
the reason why I'm jealous of this person
is really because I'm
jealous of people with big,
nice yards.
I just remember back
from my summer job days
of mowing grass,
I miss mowing grass.
I'm jealous of people who
get to mow their grass.
One day I want to go back to mowing grass,
and I wanna get the nicest
lawnmower on it that exists.
There's some of these lawnmowers,
there's big industrial ones
that you can turn on a dime.
Man, I'm so jealous of those people.
I don't wanna hurt this dream,
but I'm just telling you
that grass has really
fallen outta fashion.
It's just, it's not-
Not here.
I wouldn't do it here
in the drought stricken region.
Yeah, so you're gonna have to move.
You've got to move to the South.
No, I'm just gonna buy a big yard
or maybe just rent someone's yard,
fly there where there's like-
You could buy a field in North Carolina.
And just go there and mow it.
And you're just gonna mow it.
I don't want it to be a field, though.
I like have obstacles
and I like to have things to look at.
We can install obstacles.
It's like tapping into my childhood.
Really what we're talking about,
maybe it's a...
I'm using this term
loosely, it's a garden;
not with other plants
that need to be maintained
'cause you don't sound
like you're into that,
but maybe there's sculptures.
There's things that you
have to maneuver around.
I wanna ride a big thing.
No, no, no.
You're on a big thing,
you're mowing grass,
but you said you wanted obstacles.
I'm saying we could put
fountains, sculptures.
And so basically we've created a garden,
like a sculpture garden.
Or maybe, you know what?
I think we just created a graveyard.
I think-
Yeah, I could do that.
We just reverse engineered a graveyard.
You need to find a
graveyard in North Carolina
that maybe once a year you can cut.
I'm sure that can be arranged.
Cause I'll...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But you got there from street sweeper.
'Cause it's the same thing,
I'm jealous of both of those occupations.
And when I'm driving down the interstate
and I see there's like
mower ahead signs, I'm like,
"Oh yeah, here we go.
Contain yourself, boy."
And then I look over
there and they're like...
it's a tractor that's mowing,
and then there's this
thing that comes down
on the side.
The extension arm.
The extension arm,
it's like,
"Man, I would just love to be
able to mow down a embankment
with that extension arm."
Well, you know,
some things are easier
to organize than others,
and I think mowing
is one of the easier things to organize.
Until then, I'll just be jealous.
Okay. I'm gonna...
My number eight is Mauro Morandi.
I'm probably not saying that right.
Let me tell you about-
What's that?
Well, they're all gonna be
people, just so you know.
Okay. Who is that?
Mauro Morandi.
So I'm gonna read about Mauro.
Is this an inventor?
No.
Okay.
An architect?
Uh, no.
Okay.
This is what he looks like.
An old dude with a white beard
and the biggest bags under his eyes.
Okay.
I'm reading from a CNN article
by Silvia Marchetti-
Okay.
From 2021.
"For nearly 33 years
he lived a hermit life
on a beautiful island
in the Mediterranean,
where he was the sole inhabitant."
So the thing I am jealous about
is the fact that he got to live alone
for an extended period of time, okay?
I've always had this idea
of I would enjoy a hermit lifestyle.
It's obviously not
practical at this point.
I have established a family
that I'm not going to abandon.
Do you know what the grass
is like on the island?
I don't know.
I wanna tell you the rest of the story
because it's kind of fascinating.
"Mauro Morandi,
known as Italy's Robinson Crusoe
after developing a loyal online following,
was caretaker of the
Sardinian island of Budelli,
embracing silence, solitude,
and the peacefulness of nature
while living in an old beach stone hut.
There was no social buzz,
no fancy food, no friends,
his only companions were birds and cats."
I might change that to dogs, but...
Birds and dogs?
"He slept on a cot and had few clothes.
Forsaking all comforts,
he preached a monastic existence
of self-reflection and meditation
on Budelli's pink beach
dotted with coral dust."
So you can read more about his existence
for 30-something years on this island,
and also how he ended up there.
Apparently there was like...
I think he crashed there originally
and then he just ended up staying there.
But then the people who...
The marine park authorities
who basically...
They wanted to a evict him
to turn the aisle into an
environmental observatory.
So after years of them
trying to get him to leave,
he finally left.
"After posting a pithy
message of resignation:
'My balls are broken,'"
that's what he said-
Oh, poor guy
Which is sling for "I'm fed up."
So he was 82 when he
moved off of the island.
Oh, poor guy.
He'd been there 30 years?
Yeah.
But it says,
"Moving home and starting a new life
can be tough for anyone,
even more so for an 82-year-old
who has spent three decades
living a solitary existence
on a paradise island.
Is it possible to move on and readjust?"
I am not jealous of
this guy at this point.
"Says Morandi, the answer
is an emphatic yes."
Once I get to the end,
you'll see why I'm jealous.
"'It's never really
over,' Morandi tells CNN.
'I'm the living proof that a
second new life is possible.
You can always start over all over again,
even if you're over 80,
because there are other
things you can experience,
a totally different world.'
Proving his point,
Morandi has apparently been thriving
since moving back to civilization
on the inhabited island of La Maddalena,
not too far from Budelli."
La Maddalena
is how you said-
"'I am happy
and I have discovered the
pleasure of living the good life
and enjoying everyday comforts.'
Using his pension from his
former life as a teacher,
he's bought himself an apartment
with all the luxuries he lacked before.
He's been sharpening his
skills as a communicator.
After years of solitude,
he's now eager to talk to people,
exchange views and post
photos and comments
on social networks to
interact with the world.
He's also been writing his memoir."
So he is using social
media in a healthy way?
Yes.
That's not possible.
So, okay,
the thing I love about this guy
is he had the hermit
lifestyle for 30 years, right?
Balls got broken.
Balls got broken and he's
moved back to civilization
and he's enjoying.
He goes on to talk about enjoying a bed,
and enjoying a kitchen,
and enjoying people.
And so he's going into his
old age living a second life.
So I'm jealous of this
guy for two reasons,
the hermit thing
but also the fact that most people
when they get into their 80s,
they're not beginning something new,
they kind of...
You feel like you're in
the sunset of your life,
but he's starting something new
and experiencing a new
perspective on life.
And I'm like I don't think I'm
going to be able to arrange
a long-term hermit situation,
and I also think that it's
something that appeals to me
but I would get very bored very quickly,
so it's probably not gonna happen.
The best I'm gonna be able to do is, hey,
a week long solo trip.
But I think this guy is
living his best life,
and I'm jealous of him.
I'm gonna put my number
eight as related to this one,
so I'm moving this around.
I'm jealous,
every time I see 'em
and interact with them,
of park rangers.
And there's like a similar thing.
I don't wanna be a hermit,
I don't wanna be alone.
But if you go to like a beautiful park,
think about going to Yosemite
and you're interacting
with these park rangers...
Now, you can get on like a crappy park
and I think you gotta work
your way up to the nice ones,
like Zion or something.
Yeah, I know some folks who got...
Some Mythical Beasts who got
placed at the Salton Sea.
Oh.
But I mean, there's something to it.
So I found myself being
jealous of those people,
but then I think it's there's
probably a big downside.
You just can't go wherever you wanna go,
you got duties.
You're a caretaker of the forest,
you're like an ant,
you're like a human ant.
I like that idea.
I'm jealous that I don't have
so much of a connection with nature
that there's a certain swath of nature
that I've spent so much time in
that I'm attuned to every little change
associated with it.
So I'm jealous of that connection
that someone like a park ranger
has with a swath of nature.
Hmm.
And maybe this is akin to
the lawn mowing thing, too,
"Oh, the grass is thicker
at this time of year."
You can't mow in a national park.
There are certain places where...
I've seen weed eaters in a national park.
But not the native grasses.
You can't be cutting the native grasses.
Can't be cut. Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
But then I'm like,
"Maybe I'm just jealous
of one of those hikers
that does the Appalachian Trail,"
having the time to do that.
So I'm trying to settle on
where my jealousy really lies,
and I don't think it's...
I think it's less of an occupation
and more of a connection with nature.
Well, I think that the
hiking the Appalachian Trail,
I mean,
I still feel like we
should do it at one point.
I mean, it takes a long time.
Not necessarily the whole thing.
I mean, you're talking about isolation,
it's like that could be an insult
to the loved ones you live with.
Oh, they understand.
It's like,
"Okay, so you're so jealous
that you can't get away from me,
can't get away from us."
But there is something...
I was gonna say sexy but
there's nothing sexy about it.
There's something intriguing about it,
adventurous.
I mean, I've always had
this secret dream to do something like,
"Okay, yeah,
I am gonna hike the
Appalachian Trail this year."
Or the sailboat of it all
is something that you love the idea.
None of that is practical at this point
not just because of relationships,
but just position in life.
It's like, okay, we can't do that.
If we're gonna do something like that,
we have to be like...
Well, we're gonna make it look
like we hiked the Appalachian Trail,
and we're gonna shoot it in a week,
and it's gonna be a YouTube video.
You know?
It's like...
But we should do...
I mean, I think we should
set a date in the future.
And it should be like,
"By this time,
you have to have made plans
to do something like that,"
whether we do it together or...
Because I just think that
before you get too old,
where you can't do
something adventurous...
Like a lot of people do the shorter...
They hike that trail in the...
Is it the one that goes from...
It's in Spain,
and it goes
to a bunch of like-
I don't know that.
Oh, I know what you're talking about.
Churches or something.
It's a famous quest that people go on.
I mean, it does remind me
that we do need to get solo trips
on the books again.
That's gotta happen again.
I keep trying to find that time.
My number seven is not unrelated
to what we're talking about
'cause it's Jared Diamond.
So Jared Diamond is..
He wrote one of my favorite books,
"Guns, Germs, and Steel," right?
So he's basically...
He's also old, he's 84.
I'm just jealous of old...
I'm not jealous of...
I don't wanna be 84 right now
but I'm just jealous of how he got
from where he was
to how he got to 84
and what he's done in between.
So this guy has written
"The Third Chimpanzee,"
"Guns, Germs, and Steel," "Collapse,"
"The World Until
Yesterday," these sort of...
They're historical/scientific explorations
of really interesting things.
I mean, obviously he's like
a professor at the same time,
but he's just a guy who
has traveled the world
and been on places like
Easter Island or New Guinea.
He's a bird watcher,
which that's not something
that I necessarily aspire to,
but his bird watching
and his interest in...
His ornithology, is that what you call it?
Took him to...
He would take trips to New Guinea
to discover and observe birds.
So just somebody
who's sort of like as close
to a modern day Indiana Jones
is kinda what I'm trying to find.
He's like an explorer/writer.
Yeah. So, it's-
Like traveling in order
to then find something out
that then you can write about
that a lot of people
will read and be like,
"Man, this guy really
put it all together."
The travel and the adventure
mixed with the knowledge
that you're getting
and then synthesizing of the knowledge
into a work,
all those things are
super intriguing to me.
And so, you know...
At this point in my life, I can be like,
"Well, I can also travel,
I can also watch birds,"
but I'm not trained.
If I'm gonna write a book,
it's gonna be like "The Book of Mythical."
It's not gonna be-
I actually think you wouldn't write
"Germs, Guns, and Steel,"
I think it would be fiction
but it would still be travel related,
and you need to justify a lot of research.
I think that could be like your swan song.
Well, and I think that
there's something to...
He's done, a bunch of stuff
and he's obviously stayed really busy,
but then it'd be like
this particular quest
resulted in this particular
book, and it's like:
How many years of thinking about...
'Cause "Collapse" is really, really cool,
the 2005 book,
and it uses the story of Easter Island
and how Easter Island
basically decimated their own population
and their natural resources
because of an ideology
that they were following
with putting the statues up.
Huh.
And he uses that as an analogy
to talk about what we're
doing as a culture,
with our commitment to consumerism
and what the results of the impact
on the environment will be.
And so on this larger scale,
we're doing what they did;
but it's like: How much...
I wanna go to Easter Island,
but I don't wanna go...
He doesn't go to Easter Island
with a cool backpack
he got off of Instagram
so he can take pictures
that he puts on Instagram,
and that's the end of it,
which is what I would probably do, right?
Like, "I took my film
camera to Easter Island.
I got some cool-ass film
pictures of these statues.
Here's my carousel on Instagram.
Isn't this cool?"
"Oh man, you got an eye for photography."
And that's the end of it, right?
It's like, no, no.
This guy goes there
and he's coming to
conclusions about things
and making statements about things
and actually impacting the
way that we're moving forward
as a civilization.
He's not just trying to
get likes on Instagram.
You know what I mean?
I don't, but I know that you do.
I am jealous of Jared Diamond.
He's not going on my list, but I get that.
I think that's totally you.
Now, this is one that I
think we've talked about
that if it's not on your list,
you're gonna put it on there
because we've had this discussion
about being jealous of this duo:
the Coen Brothers.
Okay.
We talk specifically about...
First of all, they're filmmakers.
They have built their brand,
their identity on their amazing
films that they just say,
"You know what?"
And then we say things like,
"Man, they conceptualize this
film and then they just...
they get in a room and they beat it out.
And then there's a couch in
there and they'll leave it...
Some days they'll just sleep on the couch
and then wake up and keep
writing and storyboarding,
meticulously planning everything,"
that everybody gives them full
trust and creative freedom
to just do their thing;
and then every few years or
so, another one comes out.
And so that creative experience,
especially in the world of film
that was always this aspiration of ours
that we have not achieved,
is something that manifests as jealousy
when you hear about their process.
And I have somebody on my list later
for the same exact reasons.
Okay.
But I think the film part of it,
I'm jealous of that too.
It's like, oh,
conceptualizing
a world meticulously.
That's what I'm saying.
I have another filmmaker
for the same reason.
I think that there is...
It's funny.
We had that conversation
with Matthew McConaughey on this show.
Remember that?
And we kind of went
into getting his advice,
which he likes to give advice,
that's kind of what
"Greenlights" is all about.
And then we were basically talking
about our desire to create, like,
"We feel like we're being held back."
And then he said something like,
"You don't need to ask for permission."
And it's like, yeah, I understand that,
but unfortunately we still
kind of are in a place
where there is a certain
level of permission
that we have to receive, right?
You think about when
you wanna create things
on a certain level...
Sure, we can do whatever we want to
on the internet within reason
if we can mobilize our team to do it,
but it has to be very economical
in order for us to be able to pull it off,
both in time in and money.
And so I think the thing
that you're tapping
into is somebody's like,
"Hey, here's plenty of money
to do something
where we're not gonna come
back necessarily and say,
'You can't do that because of money.'"
I'm not saying they get to
do whatever they want to.
They're not spending like 500 million
on their movies or whatever.
They're still making
movies that are reasonable.
But no one is coming along...
Even what we did with
"Inside Eats," right?
Proud of the show that we created,
but we're creating it for another
audience in a lot of ways,
we're creating it for...
it's gotta work on Food Network, right?
Whereas they're just like,
"I'm making a movie that's just gonna work
for anyone who wants to see
the movie that we're making.
And we're not getting permission
from anybody creatively."
And you think about the buy-in they get.
Any talent they want is
clamoring to work with them,
it's an automatic yes.
Give me your next one.
Number six, John Mayer.
I wanted to put a musician on the list.
Okay.
And I'm sure I could have...
He's not like the end-all-be-all
I'm jealous of him
in particular more so than anybody else,
but I think that there is a...
Like, I didn't put Harry Styles on here
because I'm actually not jealous.
The thing about a guy like Harry Styles
as somebody who is defining culture;
if he wears something, it's cool;
it doesn't matter what he does, it's cool,
it's defining culture.
And John Mayer's not like
that because he's our age
and he's not making pop music anymore,
but the way that he's just kind of doing
what he wants to do musically.
Yeah.
And also the fact that he's so focused.
So this is another thing about
each person on this list.
For me, one of the things I'm jealous of
is people who have a focus.
We don't have a focus.
We have like 12 jobs, right?
But everybody on this list,
they do this one thing really
to really, really well.
That's why John Mayer can play the guitar
like a complete badass
because John Mayer has
been playing the guitar
since he was a teenager in his bedroom
for hours and hours and hours on end.
And my relationship with the guitar
is when I have a song to write
or something to figure out,
I will play the guitar;
but then weeks will pass
when I don't pick it up
because there's too many
other things going on.
So I think that somebody
who has achieved something
really admirable musically
and is operating at a very,
very high level musically,
but also just making the
music that they wanna make.
So that's a specific thing that-
I get it.
I'm not jealous of the fact
that John Mayer has dated
Katy Perry, Taylor Swift,
fill in the blank.
Jennifer Aniston.
Yeah, let's not...
I have a policy of not
bringing up his dating life
as part of my fandom of John Mayer,
period.
Yeah.
Like you said,
he's singing songs about wishing
that he was with his old high
school girlfriend, you know?
Yeah, naming their third baby.
Yeah. Right.
I have a musician on my list
for totally different reasons.
Okay.
Flea.
I'm jealous of Flea,
the bassist for the Red Hot Chili Peppers.
I mean, how old is Flea?
Give me-
I'd say 58.
Dude, give us a Google.
A Google focused on?
Flea.
Oh, you're not listening to our show.
How old is Flea?
The reason why I'm jealous
of Flea is because he's-
He's 59.
He's 59 years old and he's...
The dude can move, like...
I mean, second to Mick
Jagger, it's like this...
I mean, this dude-
Well, Mick Jagger's like
30 years older than him.
I know.
But to make that statement
about the dude can move-
20 years older.
Is astonishing for Mick Jagger.
I guess I will be jealous
of Mick Jagger one day,
but I'm not now.
I'm jealous of Flea
because I never learned
to play an instrument,
but the way that he plays...
Yes, I can get by on some
instruments for comedic effect
but I never learned to play an instrument.
And I chose him because he
channels so much of himself.
Yes, he's an excellent,
arguably the most famous...
one of the rock bassists...
One of the most famous basis, period.
I love the bass guitar, I
love what it does for music.
But the way that he
channels his entire body
into his music
and just feels it
is something that I just...
With my connection to
music, the way that it's...
I just wish I could have it flow out of me
like you see him do it.
And I spared no expense for
my Chili Peppers tickets
when they come to L.A.
Well,
I think you can potentially-
I'm excited.
Is there any DJ that also has a bass?
I'd have to learn the bass.
I'm not prepared to learn the bass
at this point in my life, honestly.
But yeah, I mean, but you
got a lot of time left.
What I'm saying is it could be cool
to play the bass as a...
Like, you're doing a DJ set-
I'm pursuing the DJ thing,
I can't pursue the bass
thing at the same time.
But just the embodiment
and to have music flow
through you in that way
that's like second nature.
Like, you're not thinking
about what you're playing,
you're just thinking about
what you wanna exude.
And you're so good at it,
you've mastered it to the point where .
That's like..
That's just...
I'm jealous of that.
I'll never have that feeling.
Well, that's probably true.
I have it in other ways-
But what I'm saying is that-
And I have experienced flow
in a way that's like I know enough of it
to want it to go through a bass.
But think about this,
if you're DJ-ing
and it's like all of a
sudden the song comes on
and it's like,
"Ah, man,
that sounds good but there's
no bassline in that song.
When is the bass gonna drop?"
And you think that the bass
is gonna drop within the song,
but then DJ Link, or whatever
your DJ name ends up being,
pulls out a bass guitar.
Yeah.
You don't even have
to actually play it.
That would be cool.
Yeah, 'cause you can do a low cut filter.
Make it look like you're playing.
You could take the bass out of anything
that you're playing
and replace it with your own bassline.
I'm just giving you ideas.
It's a great idea for
somebody, maybe I'll get there.
My number five-
It's good to have goals.
My number five is Jeff Goldblum.
Okay.
For a whole bunch of reasons.
But I will say that I
think that Jeff Goldblum,
in his advanced age...
And I'm just saying
advanced age compared to us,
he's not like about to die.
But being old
but achieving iconic status
where you can kind of say
anything that you want
and people are like,
"Jeff Goldblum said
that, or, "Jeff Gold..."
Like, If we went to a
party and somebody said,
"Jeff Goldblum's here," it would...
What would you think about that?
We'd be like, "Well, who
doesn't like Jeff Goldblum?"
I know.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's not so much what Jeff Goldblum
was able to accomplish
to become Jeff Goldblum,
which would be...
Yeah, being a famous
actor would be super fun,
but that's not specifically
what I'm jealous of.
You can be like, "Oh, look
what Jeff Goldblum has on."
Look at Jeff Goldblum in that commercial
that's about apartments,
but he just made Apartments.com cool
because he's Jeff Goldblum.
All right.
He's on my list now.
And yeah, you're exactly right.
For me, I'm just jealous of his vibe.
What he's done is he's given
himself over completely
to his eccentricities.
And there are times, talk
about tapping into flow,
that I feel like I can
unabashedly give myself
over to my eccentricities,
and it feels good,
but I don't live in that place.
I'm jealous that it seems
that he lives in that place.
But it isn't as simple
as that because he...
Jeff Goldblum...
And nothing against you,
but most people can't give themselves
over to their eccentricities-
You just you are or you aren't,
it's not a decisional thing.
No, no, no.
Well, yeah to that.
But most people can't give themselves
over to their eccentricities
and still be broadly appealing
to pretty much everybody.
Do you know what I'm saying?
He's a weird dude but
everyone likes his...
is drawn to...
I don't know anybody who's like,
"I hate Jeff Goldblum."
You know what I'm saying?
He's got a magnetism.
When Jeff Goldblum gets
super weird and crazy
and does something,
it's like it's always endearing,
it's never annoying, it's just like...
That's just so hard for people to do.
It's sort of a magic power
that most people just don't have.
I don't think there's a
version of me in the future
that could achieve Jeff Goldblum status,
it's not in my DNA makeup to be-
I think I could do it.
See, that's where I'm differing.
I'm having a difference of opinion.
Well, I don't need your opinion.
Because I think that it would appeal
to a lot of people but there's...
You leaning into your eccentricities
would not appeal to as many
people as Jeff Goldblum does.
Well, I'm already an acquired taste.
I'm not for everybody.
I've said that.
How is he for everybody?
There's a phenomenon.
There's few people like that,
that this is like you can't
hate on Jeff Goldblum.
He behaves in a way
that you would think would be polarizing,
but it's not.
He's kind of like Dolly Parton.
It's a bit of Dolly Parton.
It is.
There's a similar thing.
But in the magnetism in like:
Who can hate on Dolly Parton?
But it's a totally different vibe.
I'd love to see the two of them together.
Because I also don't get the impression
that Jeff Goldblum-
He's a pianist.
Is working as hard as Dolly Parton.
Nah, he ain't.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Dolly Parton is working hard.
Wasn't that like nine to five?
I mean, what I'm saying.
I mean-
At least nine to five all the time.
What a way to make a living.
I mean, nine to five to me
sounds kinda like banker's hours,
but-
Dolly's working way
more than nine to five.
Yeah.
But I don't think Goldblum is.
Like, what's Goldblum doing right now.
He's probably relaxing.
Something that I would
like to be with him for,
whatever it is, I'm game.
You know what?
You know, a person I'm jealous
of, it's a group of people.
When I'm mountain biking,
I got this one route I do,
it takes me two hours.
I'm going up, up, up,
only up for an hour and 20 minutes,
and then like 30 minutes
back down, give or take,
the same route.
But then you get overtaken
by a couple of people
and then you find yourself
looking over your shoulder
'cause you don't wanna be that guy
who's like you're listening to something
and then there's somebody
behind you forever
and they're trying to get by you
and like judging how slow you're going.
So I get a little self-conscious.
You learn when you turn a corner
to give a little look just to make sure
there's not somebody back there.
But then there's sometimes
when it's like people get so...
they're in so much better shape
that they'll just find a way around
even before I realize that they're there
'cause they're coming up on me so fast,
and that's a bit soul crushing.
And it's happening more and more.
But the thing that I'm noticing is that,
and I've learned to look
and immediately identify,
these people,
it's like, "This guy's got 10 years on me.
What the hell?"
He's on a e-bike.
E-bikes are really taking over.
E mountain bikes.
So they're battery driven-
So you're getting assistance
to get up the hill?
Yes.
And a lot of people judge 'em for it.
You know, I've learned
to stop judging myself
because I know where to look
on the bike 'cause they...
It's small.
The frame has a bigger
part down there, that's,
"Okay, that's where the motor is."
This guy's just trucking."
I mean, they go up so fast
it looks fun going up.
Like, I'm jealous of
these people having fun
for that hour and a half
that I'm just killing myself
so that I can experience the reward
of getting up there and
the fun of coming down,
but they're having the fun going up
and the fun coming down,
and they don't need a helicopter
from your friend planning
your perfect day.
So you're jealous of them because they-
I'm jealous because I just
can't allow myself to go there.
But I have decided I'm not gonna judge
or hate on them anymore because
it's giving them access...
I mean, they wouldn't have the ability,
I don't think.
You still have to do some work.
No, not really.
Yes, you have to pedal a little bit.
But let me tell you, they're
not even breaking a sweat, man.
It's funny-
You pedal, but no, not really.
This explains why I saw...
When Shepherd and I were
hiking up a mountain recently
on a fire road
and we saw-
Oh gosh.
Trucking.
Well, he was stopped.
He was stopped and drinking
water, but he was old.
And I was like,
"How the hell is this guy
getting up this mountain?"
He must have had an e-bike."
E-bike.
Yeah.
And there will come a day
when I will get one of those.
But I just can't allow myself to do it now
'cause that's what's keeping me in shape,
is not allowing myself
to get one of those.
Well, and you know what, you could get-
But I'm jealous that they're
experiencing that, but-
They also probably...
You don't have to use it the whole time
if you have like a standard-
Yes, but that...
There's no way.
You're sitting there
trudging in granny gear
knowing that you could zip
right on up the mountain?
No, it would never happen.
It's funny that we're
jealous of old people.
Everybody on our list is old people,
older than us.
Give me another one.
She is older.
Marina O'Loughlin, no relation.
Before this exercise, you
did not know these people.
Yeah, well-
Like, you used this as an occasion
to come up with people.
Well, let me say why.
She's a food critic.
Okay.
And she's number four on my list,
if it gives you any idea of
how important this is to me.
Someone that you just
Googled on the internet,
but food critic is really
what you're going for.
And the reason that I
did not know about her...
Well, first of all,
it's not like I'm up on
the world of food critics.
But also while she is a very
accomplished food critic,
she's known for her anonymity.
So she's not like...
When I started looking, I was like,
"I wanna find a food critic on my list,"
because I've always loved the idea
of just being someone
who gets paid to eat,
which is, again, yes,
I kind of do that already.
Yeah, you do that already.
But it's not the same.
I'm not eating at a fine
dining establishment
and then giving you my
refined opinion on it.
Well, don't let the
Mythical Kitchen hear that.
And also,
she has not positioned
herself as a personality
because she kinda talks
about the fact that...
These people who...
If you look up food critics,
most of them like, oh,
and they have this TV show,
and they have this show that they're on,
or they're a judge on this thing.
She's kind of avoided that
because she wants to maintain her...
Even though you can find
out what she looks like
and people do know who she is,
but she's got anonymity when
it comes to the restaurants,
but she has anonymity when
it comes to the public,
which as a restaurant critic,
you probably eat by yourself quite a bit.
I've always been very resistant
about eating in a restaurant by myself
or going to a movie by myself because-
Movie's easier.
I don't think I've ever
been to a restaurant alone.
But like my wife went on a solo trip
a couple years ago
and she just went to restaurants
by herself, you know?
But I'm self-conscious of it
because I'm like, "Well..."
It's fine if I just tell
the waiter I'm here alone,
but then there's this
part of me that's like,
"Yeah, but if you know
who I am, then it's like,
'Oh right, he just eats by
himself because he's camp,
he doesn't have any friends.'"
So you're jealous of
being able to eat alone
without being judged for it?
Well, that's one aspect of it.
But also if you just look at
the articles that she writes,
I think she's with "The Times" in England.
But she doesn't just...
She'll go like,
"I'm reviewing this hotel
that has a restaurant.
I'm reviewing the hotel
and the restaurant,"
and there's this like posh
hotel somewhere in Wales
and she's writing about it.
So she gets to travel.
To travel nice places,
to stay in nice places,
to eat nice food is a very appealing thing
that I like to...
I like to do those things.
But do you like to redeem
the travel by writing?
I think you're onto something here.
You wanna travel with
a purpose of writing.
Second time it's come up.
And you wanna eat.
There's definitely something to...
For me, when I experience something,
I am compelled to write about it
because it helps me to
understand it better for myself.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like when you have this experience
and you're like, "I'm gonna
put this in my journal,"
not so that somebody
can necessarily read it
but it helps me understand
what happened to me
and understand...
And remember,
I have this list in my Evernote
which is like things I like,
and I haven't added to it for a long time
but it's just I wanna remember
that this restaurant was good
or I wanna remember that this place
was a really fun place to go.
There's something about
cataloging that that is important,
but also it's just the lifestyle.
You know what you should do?
You should commit yourself
to being a Yelp writer.
That's a perfect journal,
it can be anonymous,
where you can have...
I'm sure you can look at your own account
and have a record of
everywhere you've eaten
and just a little something
that you've said about it.
Don't write it...
Don't do it for other people;
I mean, they'll benefit from it;
but maybe you'll start to get
notice because of your prose.
I don't know.
Anonymously.
Come on, man. Think about it.
Don't poo poo it.
Don't make the stink face.
This is a good idea.
I think that I want to write in a more-
You want the cred.
No, no, that's not what...
I mean, yeah, I do want cred,
but that's what I'm jealous about.
But you could still get it.
I mean, people get cred
from writing Amazon reviews.
It's a different style.
It's a different style, though.
You could be the first.
It's not experiential.
Make it experiential.
It's like, "We had the
Hawaiian shrimp combo."
No, there are more-
"Everyone at my table ordered, so..."
I don't...
It's-
No,
there are people who write
reviews in a different way.
You could do it your way.
You think there's somebody who's-
And you have a record of
everywhere that you've eaten,
and it gives you...
It's like, "Well, I
gotta eat somewhere else
'cause I gotta write about it-
You think there's somebody
who wrote Yelp reviews-
"They're counting on me."
And then transitioned into
full-time food critic?
Is that what you want?
No, I'm just saying
that I just don't think
that bridge gets there.
Is that what you want?
No, but if I'm gonna write the reviews,
I wanna be able to approach
it as a food critic
not as just a Yelper.
It just feels like a
distinctly different exercise.
Well, that's your only path.
I mean, you need a portfolio.
I think I'm just gonna keep
eating at good restaurants
and maybe start eating at them alone.
I only have what?
Two more?
This one right here...
Again, it's another older person.
Two more? I'm about...
I just gave you my number four,
so I have three more.
Oh, maybe I'm cutting ones.
This guy's 49 years old,
but he, ever since, like for decades,
he has been a prolific music producer.
And this one's much more
squarely inspirational
than it is jealous.
I actually don't know
exactly what I'm jealous
of Pharrell about,
but I think I can start
to put my finger on it.
The dude, for decades,
has been creating music, producing music,
showing up in all types of places;
of course, with the Neptunes
back in the day, but then...
I mean,
at his age,
he's still producing for the
top artist on the planet.
Like the new Kendrick album,
he produced "Mr. Morale,"
that's the only song he produced on there.
But to be on that album, which is like...
You know, it's like a
treasure, a time capsule,
it's like this artistic expression
is something that will
always be referred to
not just in hip hop,
whether you go back and listen
to it all the time or not,
it's just you can't deny it.
The fact that he's working with Kendrick,
he's working with...
And he's singing the hook
on the Pusha T album,
which I really like.
So it's like...
And he actually sang
the hook on "Alright,"
the Kendrick song from
"To Pimp a Butterfly."
So he's been around, he's in the mix,
and he's getting older.
First of all, he doesn't-
He doesn't look 49.
He look like a...
I mean, he looks so young
but he's staying young.
Again, I think this is
more of an inspiration.
But the thing that I'm jealous of
is that he's in the world
with these musicians
and artists that are
the top of their game,
he's rubbing shoulders with them,
he's creating with them.
So he's not just a fly on the wall
but he's in the mix,
and that's just like...
It's a world that's so fascinating to me,
and I just love the idea of it.
So I'm jealous that this guy gets to walk
into a room and...
If Prince were alive, he'd
go up and talk to him,
you know?
He was in that Kanye documentary.
Right.
Like, in the early days of Kanye.
Yeah.
And there's that scene
where he recognizes Kanye's talent,
and he was like no one was
expecting it at the time.
Right.
And he looked exactly
the same as he does now.
Yeah.
It's just so weird.
He'd be a cool guy to meet him.
I have a music producer in my top three,
but I he's not my number three,
so I'm gonna give you my number three.
Well, just do 'em outta order.
Okay.
Well, I'll give you my number two then.
My number two is Rick Rubin.
Oh yeah. Same thing.
See, I got you to watch
that Paul McCartney thing,
'cause you told me, the "3,2,1."
And also,
even though he doesn't
actually cameo in it,
in the second season of "Dave,"
there's like the Rick Rubin episode.
I don't remember that.
Wasn't that "Dave?"
I think fell off.
I didn't finish Dave
season two for some reason.
Really?
I gotta finish that.
I think that's the show that I saw it on.
So what about him makes you jealous?
Well,
he has simultaneously achieved
what you're talking about
Pharrell being able to achieve
in terms of being very
much in the mix of...
it's like on the cutting edge of culture
for a very long time;
but at the same time,
his personal journey of spirituality
and into meditation
and also just physically
what he looks like,
he completely departed
from the path of like,
"I am trying to be cool in this way,
and I dress cool and I..."
It's like Rick Rubin wears like a t-shirt
and shorts and flip
flops everywhere he goes,
and obviously does not do
anything to his hair or beard
except just let it grow.
Yeah.
And-
He's a musical guru.
Yeah.
And I think he's somewhat
of a spiritual guru, right?
Because he's obviously got
a high level of equanimity
in his life through his
practice of meditation,
which my understanding
is that it's very advanced and developed.
So he's just a very calm and
peaceful guy who seems to be...
He's gotten to a place where the things
that bring him pleasure
and fulfillment and joy,
he's parsed out his life in his older age
to know that, like,
"This is what I want to be doing,
and I'm gonna focus
exclusively on these things
that bring me joy,
and everything else is gonna
just fall to the wayside,
including what I look like."
You know what I'm saying?
Now, obviously the net effect
is he looks like a badass
because he looks like he
doesn't care what he looks like.
And he's got this compound in Malibu
and then he's got another place in Hawaii,
and artists just show up
for him to work his magic.
It's like he's like,
"I've set up my life
and now these people
are gonna come to me."
Yeah, so his proximity to-
His artists.
Sort of culture defining things
that keeps you kind of young
and keeps you in the mix-
But yet being totally separate
from it at the same time.
He's the only person that I know
or he's the best example of a
person who has achieved that;
being in the world but not of the world,
to use a biblical reference, right?
So he's very much in it,
he's completely in it,
but then he lives what feels like-
His outward appearance is like someone
who's living a monastic lifestyle.
The idea of being 20, 30 years from now,
I don't know, he's not
that much older than us,
but achieving that type of equanimity
but still being involved
in creating great art,
I'm jealous of that.
That. I don't know what equanimity means.
I'm trying to infer that.
It just means basically a balance,
like balance in your life:
peace and joy and-
So like life equilibrium?
Yeah.
Okay.
It's basically what you're-
You're supposed to say,
"I don't know what equilibrium means."
It's what you're trying to achieve.
It's ultimately what every...
When everybody says that
they're going after joy
or happiness-
Silent lucidity.
What they're really
talking about is equanimity
because you can't be happy all the time,
that's not a state that
you can just be in.
You're gonna have happiness,
you're gonna have sadness,
you're gonna have...
You're gonna experience the
gamut of human emotions,
but are you constantly kind
of coming back to the center?
Are you balanced?
Okay.
Do you have equanimity?
Yes.
Yeah, I do.
Thank you.
I didn't know what it meant,
but I totally am nailing that.
Okay.
So I took...
I'm taking my dogs off my list.
I was jealous of my dogs,
but I'm taking them off the list to put
whoever I put on the list
because you told me to.
Oh yeah.
But I guess I gotta keep on my list,
I'm jealous of people who
don't have to sleep a lot.
But I'm more secure in being
able to magically nap anywhere
at any time as a superpower,
so it kind of balances itself out.
I'd love to be able to have both though.
I'm a super sleeper and a super napper
but I also wanna not ever need it.
I don't think those people
really exist, though.
Maybe they don't. Yeah.
And I like hearing that.
I mean, I don't know.
They're fooling themselves.
They're depriving themselves
and they'll die young.
A lot of people have
brought into question,
I think I actually wrecked at one point,
that book about sleep.
It turns out that-
You're unwrecking the book now?
Do it.
I don't know if I wrecked it
and so I can't unrwreck it.
But if I did wreck it,
I can say that there are certain things
that the guy says in the book...
It isn't like it's all
made up and it's not true,
but there are some like
manipulation of the data
in a way to kind of like make his point.
But one of the things that he talks about
is that those people who say that,
"Oh, I only need four hours of sleep,"
that's actually much more
rare than probably not.
They're foolish.
It's like probably not.
Actually you probably would be healthier
if you were getting six
to eight hours of sleep
or seven to eight.
By the way,
the people who are literally full of
then they got a problem too.
You're not jealous of them.
No, no, no, no, no.
I've been on a really good run lately.
Yeah. So I don't know, man.
So do you have two left or one left?
Two.
Okay.
So give me your two and
I'll give you my one.
Well, how about I'll give
you one, then you do one,
then I can give you...
I go last.
I think we might have same number-
'Cause I only have one left.
I think we might know
they're the same number one.
I only have one left.
Yeah, so I'll do mine
and then you do yours
and then I'll do mine.
Exactly.
But you said, "Give me your two."
I thought you wanted
me to go two in a row.
No, give me your two.
I'll give you my one,
then you give me your one.
Oh, I thought you said,
"Give me your two,"
like-
I did say give your two.
No, no, no.
I thought you were like,
"Give me your last two."
That's what I heard you say.
"Hey, give me both of your two
so that I can wrap this up."
That's what I interpreted that.
You were saying, "Give
me your number two."
Believe the best in me, man.
I want you to have the grand finale.
My number two was Rick Rubin.
My number three is Jordan Peele.
For the same reason-
You already...
He's an inspiration.
He made that list.
Well, 'cause I'm jealous of him.
Okay.
For all kinds of reasons,
for all the reasons
that I talked about him
being an inspiration before.
Give me a different reason then.
The Coen brothers thing,
and that he has gotten to a place
where he is exercising
this creative control
over these film projects
and everyone is just like,
"I can't wait for the
new Jordan Pele movie."
Nope.
You know?
Still waiting, getting ready.
And also the fact
that there's a bit of a parallel career
in that he was a...
I'm not saying I wanna go
and make movies by myself,
but I'm saying the fact
that he was in this comedic duo
that you never expected either of the...
"Oh yeah, it makes sense,
they might go on to be actors,"
but to become this master filmmaker
who was sitting on this
incredible skill this whole time.
So the way that he has basically reshaped
any and all expectations about him
based on what he's done in the past
is something that I'm almost 100% sure
that that's not something
that is gonna occur
in my lifetime.
As much as I like to achieve things
and as much confidence as I have,
I understand the extreme
unlikeliness of like, oh,
I'm gonna fart out some
culture defining film that's...
You know what I'm saying?
So it's just like something
that I'm always going to be jealous of,
is the fact that he was
able to pull that off.
That's inspirational
and jealousy inducing.
My number one.
I can't remember if you put
this on your inspirational list,
this guy, but I did not.
My ranking is kind of arbitrary,
but I think this is a
good one to end on for me.
Okay.
I'm jealous of Bo Burnham
because we came up together
on the internet, you know?
And so it's like having a
very similar starting point
for him to be in this place
where
he's not beholden to the internet
in the way that we are.
And when we saw him at that party
and hadn't talked to him in so many years
and he was like...
He was very nice.
And he said something to the effect of,
"You guys have made it
work on the internet.
You've made it work for you.
And you're still doing it."
I think he actually said something like,
"You guys are a cultural
institution," just...
I mean, 'cause I remember those...
He's super nice guy, super complimentary,
but there was a part of me that was like,
"Yeah, but like, man,
I mean, it's just a...
We both know that it's
just a dumb internet show
where we eat things every...
We're not doing 'Inside' on Netflix."
You know what I'm saying?
My insecurity told me that
I did not hear him say,
"Man, I really respect you guys
in terms of
your comedic sensibility
and comedic expression."
We have this thing where we
want comedians that we respect
to like the things that we create
and not just be mesmerized by the fact
that we were successful on a platform
that they didn't have the stomach for
is how I felt like...
I felt like that was what
was in his compliment,
was that like,
"I didn't want to keep
playing the YouTube game.
Kudos to you guys for
doing that to an extreme."
His artistic expression in "Inside," yeah,
it makes me jealous because I feel
like not only do we have a
very similar starting point
but we have similar
capabilities and sensibilities.
It's just-
Well, similar in that
they kind of are geared
in the same way but not to the degree,
just in my opinion.
Yes. Yeah.
Okay.
In other words,
we ain't talented as Bo Burnham, you know,
so by long shot,
but we like to do the same types of things
that he does.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it makes it extra...
It's salt in the wound, so to speak,
I must have just blocked this one out
because he's definitely on my list.
And I would say that for all
the reasons that you just said-
Now you have to knock off your number one,
so I get to finish.
I'll knock off the old guy
who lived on the island.
He's off the island now.
I think one of the things that
I'm jealous with Bo Burnham
and also my number one,
which I'll get to in a second,
is the fact that we
have not only created...
the decisions that
we've made in our career
in order to remain relevant and successful
and to build a company
has involved quite a bit
of giving of ourselves,
not just our time but
literally giving of ourselves.
Words that come out of our
mouths and go on the internet,
there's so much that we're
putting out there of ourselves;
on this podcast, being vulnerable, right?
And
it was almost like when you take "Inside,"
Bo Burnham hasn't been saying
anything on social media,
he doesn't say anything on Twitter,
he doesn't have a podcast,
he's not constantly talking about himself
and what he thinks, right?
But then he bottles all that up
and puts it into this hour long special
that is like,
"This is what I've been thinking.
These are my thoughts,"
not given to you in this steady stream
where you can't escape me
by going on the internet,
but like,
"If you wanna tune into this
fire hydrant of expression
and creativity and vulnerability,
it's in this special
that I've been working on
for this length of time.
And now I'm working on this other thing,
and you know what,
you'll be around for...
And I don't have to stay on your radar
with every little piece of
content that I put out."
I'm jealous of that.
I'm jealous that somebody
can be so prolific
yet
not have some so much
volume in their output.
Before you give your number one,
do you think that this has been
a positive experience for
us to have this discussion?
Like, I was more worked
up at the beginning,
you brow's a little
crinkled at this point.
Do you feel like we're
getting things out there
and that it's cathartic or
that it's fomenting something?
I think those are the same.
So I think that if you have a frustration,
by taking it out,
looking at it and expressing it...
I mean, this is what I
do in therapy, right?
I'm assuming this is what
you do in therapy as well.
If there's something that
is on your mind in this way,
I think that it is only
good to vocalize it
and actually examine it.
So ultimately, yes, very positive,
but it may not be like,
"Oh, this is gonna put me
in a good mood right now,"
but that's not how I'm gonna judge
whether or not it is a net positive.
You know me,
I get very creatively frustrated, right?
Because of I'm extremely
grateful for all the success
and the things that work,
but I'm also frustrated
that we can't just be like,
"Let's just create this
aspirational thing,"
and to be financed in the way
that we want it to be
financed, and just like,
"Here's this thing that we thought of
and we spent all this time on."
But for me, that desire's
not gonna go away.
When I think about this list of people,
it isn't like,
"Oh man, I have regret
about choices we've made,"
I just think, "I'm still very young,
I have a lot of life left.
And the way that I'm
going to position myself
in the future is to get in the
way of more of these things
that I admire in these people," right?
You want to actually
engineer your life in a way
where you move towards the
things that are inspiring.
So it may be frustrating,
but I think that that frustration
is just us being honest about...
I mean, I get tired of seeing
myself on the internet,
to be perfectly frank about it.
You know what I'm saying?
It's just like,
"I kind of wish I didn't
have to constantly be
in multiple streams of content
in order for this to work."
Bob Burnham doesn't have to do that.
Bob Burnham doesn't have to
make an internet video today
to be talked about and to be appreciated.
And you may say,
"Well, you guys don't have to either."
And I'm not saying that I'm burned out
or anything like that.
I'm just saying that I'm jealous
of someone who can be like,
"I'm gonna ball it all up and
give it to you in this way."
That's not our business model.
Our business model is
constant contact and content,
and it works and people appreciate it,
but I would be dishonest if I said,
"Well, I'm jealous of the people
who don't have to do that,"
which leads me to my
number one, Donald Glover,
for all the same reasons
but I think even more so
than Bo Burnham because-
He does so many different things.
So you can be like,
"I am going to become a musical artist.
And I'm not just gonna
be a good musical artist,
I'm gonna be a great musical artist.
And I'm not just gonna be
a great musical artist,
I'm gonna be a culture
defining musical artist,"
in a way that every person
who's doing only music aspires to
is such a-
Yeah, but then I'm gonna have this show
that's like an artistic expression.
Yeah.
And I'm gonna make choices on
that show that are for him.
Are you caught up?
I'm not caught up on this season.
I haven't started.
I'm waiting for the right time to hit it.
And then everything that I just said,
he doesn't...
"Oh, let's go watch Donald
Glover's Instagram story today."
It doesn't exist
because it doesn't need to.
I mean, really,
it's really a question like:
Would you do-
I mean, first of all,
neither one of us are very active
on social media to begin...
but our presence on
social media is very high
because the Mythical
presence is very high.
But if you never had to tweet again,
you never had to put your
opinion out about anything,
you never had to say
where you stood on this,
you never had to be,
"Here's a picture of me
doing this," ever again,
and you could just be like,
"Here's the thing that I wanted to create
and you guys can watch it if you want to,"
would you choose that?
Well, I feel like the only thing...
I don't really tweet.
I don't really share much.
I've kind of hit a lull.
There's been sometimes
when I'll get back into it,
but the majority of the
time I'm not into it
so then I just feel guilty
that I'm not doing enough
from a professional standpoint.
You're right.
So to me it's about...
Like, it's an obligation
that I'm not fulfilling,
so it's more about the
feeling of not fulfilling it.
So I don't feel like I have to trade it.
But in general, would at I trade...
I don't know.
I feel like would I trade
my experience right now
for any of the people that I'm jealous of?
And if you have to take a
kitten caboodle, I wouldn't.
Yeah, I agree with that.
I mean, I don't know any
of these people personally.
You know?
Yeah.
Again, I do read things in
the MrBeast profile piece,
it's like, okay,
it's like things about his existence
are things that I'm not jealous of.
It's like when you get into the specifics.
I don't know Bo Burnham personally,
I don't know what his
experience is, but like-
But even his special came
from a place of pain.
Right.
So, yeah.
I completely agree-
So it's like
I don't want that.
I'm not saying I want to be-
And I'm like, "Man,
I'm in a pretty nice spot
and I'm pretty content."
I'm actually...
I'm jealous of aspects of things,
but if you can't pick and choose
then it's like there's no one
that I would trade my life for.
It's like-
I completely agree with that.
As a matter of fact, I was
telling Jessie about this.
I know we're getting
long here, but who cares?
I was telling her recently, I was like,
and I was talking to my
therapist about this too.
I was like...
I haven't struggled with depression.
There hasn't been...
I mean, I get depressed at
times like anybody who gets sad
or kind of gets down in
the dumps or whatever,
but I haven't struggled
with it like a diagnosable-
Well, yeah, I wouldn't call
those things depression then,
but yeah, go ahead.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I just was talking to
'em recently and I was like,
"You know, I keep sort of...
There's been multiple times
over the past couple of months
where I'm just like, 'I'm happy.'"
You know?
And I tend to not be a
very satisfied person.
I'm very, very driven,
like to a maniacal point,
and I get a lot of satisfaction
out of coming up with
something and then being...
and then like, "I'm gonna go after that,"
I'm geared to that.
So there's not a lot of time
where I just stop and think,
"Oh, I'm happy.
I've got it really, really good."
But there's just been a number
of times recently where...
And I don't know
if it's with Locke getting
ready to go to college
and it's like our family
dynamic is about to change
or whatever,
but just kind of just
recognizing that like:
Man, if there is a universe,
if there are really multiple worlds
and there's other versions of me out there
who made other decisions
at different points
and ended up in different places,
I just can't imagine many of them
being better than this.
I recognize that how great
everything has worked out.
So I completely,
by talking about my
frustrations creatively
and how I love the fact that Donald...
I'm jealous of the fact that Donald Glover
and Bo Burnham don't have to
have a social media presence
because their creative presence
is so overwhelmingly significant,
I'm jealous of that,
but I completely agree with you
that I'm not saying I wanna trade places
with anybody on the list.
Yeah, I think that we have...
I mean,
we're enjoying success.
We're at like a great point in our careers
where there's things...
there's the relationship with our fans
and the relationships that
we have with each other,
all of it is kind of
like we're in a good spot
personally and professionally.
I think another part of it is,
if you focus on the professional part,
we do have a lot of
freedom and power to say,
"Okay, we can..."
If there's anything we want
to go after or restructure,
or anything that we wanna do,
it's like we have the ability to do that.
Well, we don't have the ability
to do anything we wanna do
and have...
like to work with any actor we want
or to get any film we want made
or to stretch our legs
creatively in any way possible,
but compared to most people
in an artistic field,
we have so many more options
and so much more power
to orchestrate our lives.
You know?
And I think that that level
of autonomy is a blessing.
It's not a guarantee to find
ourselves in this position.
Well, I think I'm very grateful for that.
So in a sense, when you say,
"Well, you could play
a bass while DJ-ing,"
it's like it's just a crazy
thing to be able to say.
And, yeah, it's funny that you
said it but it's also true.
It's like we're at a point in our lives
where we do have the
freedom to pursue things
and we don't really have
to get too much buy-in
for things that we would wanna go after.
Yeah.
You know?
So it's really on us.
We don't need to ask permission.
We need to ask forgiveness.
Well, you know,
in an effort to wrap it up.
I think that the way I've
been sort of framing it,
and this is with the help of my therapist,
is if you're a busy person,
and most people are busy,
you kind of have to ask yourself,
"Am I putting life giving
things onto my plate
or life taking things onto my plate?
And am I taking life taking
things off of my plate
and then putting life
giving things on it?"
And you know, as an individual,
what those things are, right?
Because even in a profession like ours,
in which it's like, hey,
it feels like it's all
fun and games to an extent
because we do this...
we're ridiculously lucky and fortunate
to have the jobs that we have
and to be able to do
the things that we do,
but even we can still make decisions
to put a bunch of life
taking things on our plate,
the things that don't bring us joy,
the things that seem obligatory,
things that don't get
us into creative flow,
whatever those things might be.
And so I think going through
a list like this, to me,
the things that I identified with
in the majority of these people
is what I would envision
being a life giving thing to me, right?
So it's a way to kind of evaluate...
All right, again, we're
still very, very young,
and like you said,
there's so much opportunity
and there's so much freedom,
but what kind of decisions
are you gonna make?
Are you gonna make decisions
that are fear based,
that are designed to
fulfill some obligation
that you put on yourself
or an obligation that you
think exists out there
from someone, or are fans or whatever,
or are you gonna make decisions
to do things that give you life and joy
and turn you into Rick Rubin in 20 years?
Right?
Like, what's your version
of a satisfied old man
full of equanimity?
If you haven't listened to
the Kendrick album, I mean,
it is about his personal journey,
a lot of it through therapy.
And at the very end, you hear him say,
"I chose me, I'm sorry. I chose me."
That's the hook.
"I chose me, I'm sorry."
I mean, there's a lot going on there
and I don't fully understand
all of it, but yeah,
it's like...
There's also some Eckhart Tolle in there,
so you should check that out.
Elon Musk was on the list.
I didn't mean to make the-
I have listened to it.
I've listened through one time.
I mean, I recommend it but that's-
That's not your rec?
That's lame to make a Kendrick Lamar album
your recommendation.
Just do it.
Just do it, man.
No, my recommendation is:
Do not share socks with your children.
Okay.
All right.
You know?
Nuff said.
I mean, if you haven't started yet...
If you think to yourself like,
"Yeah, but we kind of like
we wear the same socks,"
do not let it begin, okay?
The only thing in my life
right now-
Have you gotten
a fungus on your foot?
It has nothing to do with fungus.
It has to do with the
availability of socks.
Because when you are all
taking socks from Dad's drawer,
because you Locke and
you Shepherd do not...
They have to do their
own laundry in our house,
that's how it works.
Oh. Mm-hmm.
Which means laundry doesn't get done,
their laundry doesn't get done.
And so somewhere in their room
there's an abyss of
socks, most of them mine.
And so I hate it, I hate that I do this,
I go on the internet and I buy more socks
instead of making them
wash their clothes, which,
I mean, I don't know, man,
it's just brought...
The only thing in my life right now
that's not making me happy
is this sock situation,
and I feel like it's all my fault.
And so now the only thing I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna buy more socks
and I'm gonna create...
The drawer in my room
that they currently use
is gonna be the dummy drawer,
they're not gonna listen to this episode,
and that's where they're
gonna get their socks,
which will run out very soon.
I'm creating a new spot that
I'm not gonna tell them about
where I actually keep my socks.
Oh, yeah. Okay.
You don't wanna be the
dad that has to do this,
so just don't begin sharing socks.
Your life sucks, man.
♪ 188-EARPOD1 ♪
Next week.
#EARBISCUITS.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.